virtual reality holds a key to the
evolution of personal life with a vision
of the future I have a game in my ass my
max play right now
yeah okay mercury Arthur has been
getting a lot of attention lately it is
certainly an invoke subject but I feel
that it's being criminally overlooked
for what might end up being one of its
most important applications and that's
brain training and making me smarter
lawnmower man had it right
[Music]
so how my virtual reality make you
smarter
why do I think it's going to be a
crucial tool for brain training in the
future what I understand the answer the
first thing you need to understand is
what brain plasticity is and what its
role in our intelligence is I've talked
about this on this channel before and of
course on my website brain plasticity
describes the ability for our brains to
form new neural connections to burst new
neurons generally to change shape in
response to the way we use it as much
like training you're bisecting your pets
or making larger trained certain brain
areas by using them or or makes them get
larger too and result in the respective
improvement in your cognitive abilities
so there are many ways you can increase
brain plasticity and that's something
else I've talked about in the past but
all intents and purposes are brain
plasticity slows down what once we reach
adulthood and there are many theories as
to why this is but generally people tend
to accept they want to reach a certain
age to kind of switch switches in the
brain and we become less plastic we've
reached out up hoods and so much like
our throws place clothes over you stop
growing so to deserve brain plasticity
brain plasticity slowed down you can see
this in a lot of psychological theories
even the don't reference brain
plasticity such as Chomsky's language
acquisition device
he believes that after a certain age it
becomes more difficult to learn
languages and we would certainly
probably say that our own experiences
reflect that but I think that there's a
possible alternative thing going on here
it's not the fact that we reach a
certain age that prevents us from being
able to learn so much it's actually the
fact that at that age we stopped needing
to learn so much so when you learn a new
subject or you try and learn new
language or when you try to take up
electronic engineering at any age your
brain responds by producing more of the
neurotransmitters that regulate brain
plasticity so you produce more dopamine
more BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic
factor
more nerve growth factor etc these are
the chemicals that make your brain more
plastic so if you were to start learning
the subject right now your brain produce
more those chemicals and you would
become better at learning as you
practice learning now imagine being an
infant you're born into the world and
suddenly you're thrust into this reality
you have to learn how to walk you have
to learn how to talk you have to learn
what the things you can see all are and
also how you're able to move in that
space and how your senses synchronize
you're learning how to balance and how
to interact with people and you're
learning your own body
so just everything is new so your brain
is flooded with new information and that
means it's learning at a rate that it
never will do again and so your brain is
flooding itself with brain fried paneer
trophic factor and dopamine and all the
things that it needs to become as
classic as possible it's as though you
were learning a million new languages at
once so that might be why it's more
plastic in childhood and then it might
also explain why it kind of tapers off
as we get older because we become more
familiar with our world we learn how to
walk around and how to interact with
people and then this continues more and
more as we get older we learn to drive
that's new we learn new subjects at
school we learn how to interact with
people and we might go off to college or
we might start and finish it all
learning all new stuff but gradually we
know how to drive and we've learned how
to interact with people we stop meeting
new people we stop traveling so much we
get into a rut and so the brain becomes
less plastic because it has less reason
to learn and so when we try and learn
something new it's more difficult so
this is a problem with the way many of
us live and simply by learning new
things and continuously taking on new
challenges we can make our brain more
plastic
so basically we're learning how to learn
and we become better at picking up any
new skill or any new information but
with virtual reality it might be
possible to take this a whole step
further by forcing the brain to adapt to
entirely new realities to imagine a
world where you're moving but every
movement is backward and where things
are moving quicker and where
you don't know what anything in your
environment is and where your sensors
emerged
you could have create whole new
synesthetic experiences or you could
create the world where using yourself in
the third person imagine moving and
seeing yourself move from the third
person it would force your brain to
shift the way it works and to learn
almost as much new in terms of how to
interact with these virtual realities as
it is new when it was born into our
reality not quite the same extent
because you've got this foundation of
knowledge to work on and you know you do
and you not gonna be subjected to that
permanently but just this huge wash of
new information to learn and a new modes
of moving even through this world
there's one virtual reality game account
of all it's called where you're in a
dream yesterday pedal along the ground
with your hand it's a great way of
getting a believe lack of positional
tracking and virtual reality at the
moment but basically you could create
whole new ways of interacting to these
worlds and your brain would have to
adapt to that
so just instead of just learning a new
skill you're learning a whole new
movement and a whole new environment and
many new stimuli so that's how I think
brain plasticity could be enhanced
through VR by submerging ourselves into
completely alien realities and forcing
our brains with that then when we return
to this one we'll have some of that
brain plasticity leftover some increase
the new transmitters to enhance our
learning you might find it easier to
take on new skills flash just my theory
that's my hunch but if I get my hands on
it HTC vive or perhaps their new
standalone headset that they're making
for Google daydream then maybe I'll have
a go at making some entirely backwards
and strange realities to see if that
does confuse the brain enough to trigger
some dormant plasticity anyway there's a
cool thought and I hope you found it
interesting
if you did then please like this video
maybe subscribe to the channel leave a
comment down below I'd like to know your
thoughts and I'll see you in the next
one I've talked on this channel about
fitness about brain training about
nootropics
technology productivity martial art you
name it so if that sounds good and you'd
like to see more content like this then
I've seen the next one thanks for
watching and bye for now
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh Jonny Quest you really understand
beginner D you've unleashed upon your
world